okay no game with us some detectives dog
never played them let's just check
quickly it's got the name in there no
it's a nun international master from
from the US it's got a pretty high
rating here 24 48 yeah there should be
five is an interesting a line yeah just
play t5 it might take now and then play
deform trying to argue that this pawn
moves are not very useful this is some
most likely a valid point okay let's try
Knight to f5 applying some pressure on
d4 and III we need to be cautious that I
don't fall too far behind in development
this is certainly a danger here okay
let's take them and now this one okay
let's just think I'm think a bit here to
have something better
yeah I want to cancel my take on III now
with the porno you can also take see
fire first cannot rescue this night
anyway ok now the questions of a castle
he takes on c5 is this a big deal wanted
to play rupee aid applying pressure on
III I've got two bishops and this dark
square Bishop is a potentially very
dangerous piece all that surprising what
about D for now is default a problem
look so strange
I'm completely amazed isn't justice a
p-side I don't understand it
you cannot take with the pawn be of
course and Queen takes Queen take see
one is hanging so this is just just a
piece for nothing I think
no idea what you overlooked them
yeah my next move will just be okay it
doesn't resign okay what about 92 f5 or
ef5 on e4 queen deform exchange queens
looks like pretty easy solution takes on
f5 fight I kept show you one so Queen
should be should be exchanged now and
nobody's got two pawns you know okay so
it's all so I'm strategically nice for
me because I've got very good pieces and
dark square control so you don't think
the the end game you should should be a
problematic okay let's figure out the
night to should go to see six or ecigs
hmm now let's go let's go to let's go
here keeping an eye on the e5 square
young covering c7 okay
one to speed up a bit this might not be
the most exact move but wow really hmm
ok maybe wants to go to to d4 ok I want
to get this this Bishop back to f8 and
then and if you have a c5 this before
the play a five try to sort nap here the
some the queenside Bishop c4 ok what
about it's a five now it looks fine on
b5 have captured c5 with check and this
leaves a to hanging so I could capture
here ok I need to I need to pay a little
bit of attention it's a shack it's a
check here then I've got Bishop e6 it's
worried a bit about Bishop c4 of course
but this covers all nicely now taking my
resign yeah ok this is really over I'm
just a piece up now got the points back
c5 is also basically gone Roxy one I can
just play Roxy to or something yeah it
just blended here with with Queen d2
well I like the position I've got the
two bishops and c5 is some not the
greatest extra porn for white and III is
so there's also problem he doesn't have
a very convenient move to cover this
actually King f2 look so looks very
strange queen t 3 i'll just play
Bishop f5 I don't know maybe this wasn't
wasn't such a great great setup for
white how to say oh maybe you should
consider something else here but okay I
like the position of two bishops I'm
bound to be worth something here because
the position opens up and the dark
squares are rather weak from White's
cancer should be okay okay and it's game